مشاهدينا عمليه تفجير التي شهدتها اسطنبول
قبل ساعات اعاده الى الاضواء مجددا ميدانت
تقسيم التاريخيه يقع الميدان شهير في
منطقه بيولوفي قلب اسطنبول الحديثه وهو
نقطه الجذب السياحي الرئيسيه وتعود تسميته
الى انه كان مركزا لتقسيم امدادات المياه
وتوزيعها في العهد العثماني يقتظ ميدان
تقسيم بالمطاعم والمتاجر والفنادق
وويكالات الاسفار من نجعله مقصدا ترفيهيا
للسياحي والاتراك وهو يضم نصب الجمهوريه
التذكاريه والمحطه الرئيسيه لشبكه مترو
انفاق اسطنبول
يمثلوا الميدان وجهه مثاليه للمظاهرات
والاحداث الاجتماعيه والوطنيه وقد كان على
مدى اكثر من نصف قرن ساحه للاحتجاجات
والفعاليات السياسيه المنوئه للسلطه
وتتفرع من الميدان شوارع كثيره اشهروها
شارع الاستقلال الذي وقع فيه تفجير اليوم
ويبلغ طوله تقريبا ثلاثه كيلو مترات وهو
يحتوي الكثير من المباني الاثريه والملاهي
والعديد من السفارات والقنصليه